the town center of AK northern France
recovering after several days of
torrential rain where residents still
need to use tractors to get around the
flooded
streets the waters may have begun to
recede but the entire area is still
under a red weather
warning this is the second time in as
many months that such significant
flooding has hit the region raising
fears that this phenomenon could be The
New Normal
here as firefighters began to install
pumps to clear the flood waters France's
environment Minister paid a visit
promising an exceptional response to
deal with what has been an extraordinary
season for
weather we don't have a uniform
situation across all the areas there are
sectors where we have repeated
difficulties and others where
fortunately we have a little less but we
need to find a way of coordinating the
work taking place in one area so that
doesn't exacerbate the problems in the
other in Germany rescue workers in the
city of oldenberg near the North Sea
Coast put up temporary dams to stem the
flooding from the hunt
River already badly affected by the
weather residents are bracing themselves
for more rain in the coming
days yet despite the forecast some are
refusing to leave the area I will not
leave my farm behind we have horses and
so on to take care of
it's not that simple a Race Against Time
and the elements as they battle an
already critical situation Sonia Gago Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler